I've been rejected
I'm Greg Alba we are going to watch
today from the channel mighty raccoon
Avengers end game trailer but everybody
is Deadpool I remember seeing that one
he did last year I think or earlier this
year infinity war but everyone is that
pool it was earlier this year
mighty wreck who makes great videos if
you guys haven't seen any of his videos
I'm telling you they're totally worth it
go subscribe to his channel as soon as
you can if you have it on a completely
separate no totally unrelated I found
out today that Penny Marshall passed
away Penny Marshall directed some pretty
classic films big which I found out was
the first movie directed by a woman to
have ever surpassed a hundred million
dollars of the box office which is
awesome to hear makes sense it's a great
film and she also directed a league of
their own my personal favorite film that
she directed is a film called awakenings
which is one heartbreaking movie but so
beautiful
simultaneously I love that film most
underrated like performance by both De
Niro and Robin Williams it's a big loss
in the world today big loss in Hollywood
she made some amazing films so first off
thank you penny for making films that
are so important in the film industry
such landmark films and of course your
family and your loved ones are in our
prayers
on that note weird transition to this I
just wanted to say a quick thing about
that let's watch this video like my new
beanie
hey that's cool
anyway I just wanna know
[Music]
last
purple Homer Simpson exactly the same
story
it might be a 50% all of the creatures
you know then I don't feel something
we lost all of us I'm gonna cry
we lost friends
we lost a part of ourselves that's what
happens when you run up the folks
[ __ ] this is the fight of our
lives
oh Jesus cut the crap I hope this
doesn't work let's hope it does because
I don't want to see you
[Music]
[Music]
look guys we have to travel back in time
to stop that Bruce Willis looking
[ __ ] it's confusing yeah I know
fine well work that's great that's great
love the editing of it dude I like how
you actually made a little extra effort
to kind of have a little story here that
it's Deadpool talking to Wolverine
slash Logan at the very beginning and
then even when he's doing the Captain
America bit and he's looking at the
photo of Logan so you actually had like
a little tail happening here the jokes
about Thanos looking like purple Homer
Simpson and Bruce that's some funny [ __ ]
because at one point III that the
impression is so good I don't know the
the impersonation of Ryan Reynolds that
I had to check myself and go is that is
that actually Ryan Reynolds I mean I
overtime like oh that's not really right
around but at first I thought it was a
really good stuff you're editing in the
way you blend together looks so natural
I mean just with the mask at the top of
it that look cool because it blended so
well in with the cinematography of it
speaking of which Deadpool in the actual
Avengers 2 you're so good at blending
the actual visual effects inserts
because you really know how to match it
with the lighting which it hasn't appear
seamless so the way you cut this up and
the way you do the inserts it's just
better than I've ever seen it before
this is actually your best looking one I
don't know that your funniest one but
it's your best-looking one that's for
sure this is a great video man
congratulations on the success of it I
could see what people wanted me to check
this out because this is some really
funny stuff and it does make you wish
Deadpool would be part of the MCU as
well guys go subscribe to the mighty
racoon Channel before I wrap this video
up I do want to give a patron of the day
shout-out to a handsome man
a beautiful man named TJ TJ oh you a
Google hangout buddy running pretty
behind on that it's the holidays and you
recently have had a baby within the past
year I think like I've said before you
got to make sure to keep the marriage
itself
hot and happen and keep it alive buddy I
suggest that this year you go all hohoho
out with you and your lady get her a
sexy mrs. Claus outfit you get all jolly
you like I think she should be sexy mrs.
Claus but you get an actual fat suit get
the beard and everything look like real
Santa Claus and she's sexy mrs. Claus
make sure your daughters in the room
because it's good to expose your kids to
that I feel like I'd be a great parent
if there's one thing I learned from my
family it's that if you're gonna have to
do it while they're still babies it's
best to keep them in the room and make
sure that they are still in your line of
sight so my Christmas present to you
don't take your eyes off your daughter I
feel like every time I give you a shout
out about Skyland I try to push the
boundaries a little bit more but I
couldn't even fully commit to that I'm
sorry anyway teach I'll be talking with
you soon buddy I hope you have a Merry
Christmas that you're able to make some
jolly ol love with with the missus
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification ballot check us on
patreon we got TV show reaction watch
along for many of shows and we do weekly
Q&A s John does music video coverage
plenty of reward tiers we love to have
you come with your object today